Grand Theft Auto 5 has certainly taken
its time arriving on PC but come
tomorrow Los Santos will no longer be
console exclusive and when a big PC game
lands mods are short follow GTA 4 had a
ton of awesome mods including graphical
improvements modifiers to make things
ultra realistic the ability to recruit
bodyguards and turning explosions into
bigger explosions because why the heck
not based on all that cool stuff here
are 5 mods we really want to see make a
return in grand theft auto 5 grand theft
auto 5 already looks way better than it
ever did on ps3 or 360 but if we've
learned anything from GTA 4 if modders
can always kick the graphics up a notch
while there are a lot of great visual
enhancement mods floating around the
very best has to be icenhancer by hossam
Kolani which makes GTA 4 on PC look even
better than the vanilla version of GTA 5
the new zealand-based technical artist
mud is built upon a pre-existing and
these theories and updates all the
in-game textures exponentially as well
as including impressive new lighting
weather and post-processing effects a
huge advantage to playing GTA on PC is
that the game can stay graphically
impressive for years thanks to mods like
this one
next up is customizable weapons and
vehicles
basically we need Star Wars and we need
it modded into la santé if lightsabers
Millennium Falcon's and speeder bikes
aren't your thing though then why not
consider the endless possibilities of
all this other custom crap you can roll
down Vinewood in your very own Batmobile
or if you're a fan of tangle we might
get a remake of Rapunzel's frying pan
from GTA 4 I'm among the people who
think we have way too many zombie games
but admittedly even I would play GTA 5
if los santos fell victim to a zombie
outbreak GTA 5 could totally turn their
thriving criminal metropolis into a
terrifying zombie riddled sprawling city
GTA 4 already cracked out some
incredible zombie focused mods which
gave the city a totally different feel
thanks to all the shambling foes can
feel brains Rockstar might not repeat
the undead nightmare we saw with Red
Dead Redemption but with any luck mod
creators will deliver again and we'll
get to see just how batshit crazy
trailer can be when required to mow down
a zombie horde
if you loved being Superman and iron man
in Liberty City you're not alone the
superhero mods of GTA 4 were among some
of the most popular so hopefully we'll
get the chance to do it all again in GTA
5 the GTA 4 Iron Man mod was awesome you
could fly punch the crap out of
everything and take up residence in the
stock Tower the enormous world of GTA 5
seems like it would be the perfect
setting to fly around dishing out some
sarcastic Tony Stark branded justice or
you could try out another Avenger like
the menacing Hulk and smash just about
anything
traverse buildings a Spider Man or
become the ultimate beacon of justice by
stepping into the heroic albeit
kryptonite sensitive shoes of Superman
all of these were possibilities in GTA 4
but now that all the criminal scum has
been wiped out from Liberty City it's
time to bring them all to Los Santos
finally one of the very best GTA 4 mods
that we'd love to see make its way over
to GTA 5 is the chance to play the game
as a cop in a city riddled with crime
and all sorts of wrongdoing you might
find that knocking out strangers for
their pocket change just doesn't jazz
you like it used to and you've had
enough of living outside the law if that
happens and you have this GTA 4 mod
installed you can adopt the role of a
serving and protecting police officer
who issues citations to crooks
stretching the speed limit engages in
shootouts with Los Santos is nastiest
and runs red lights without feeling bad
about it because you're allowed damnit
let me know if you've played any
particularly cool Grand Theft Auto 4
mods and what kind of mods do you want
to see when grand theft auto 5 comes to
p-speed I can't you can soon